[Music]
there is no peace
if one helicopter came here it would be
enough for all of kandahar
why don't they use helicopters against
them they targeted me
they tried to kill me if they killed me
then who will look after my children
[Music]
[Music]
we are now in control of more than 70 of
the territories
it is simply because the people know us
very well and the afghan people have no
problem dealing with us
[Music]
[Music]
the situation is going to be bad police
and border forces have equipment
problems
commandos and the national army are
based a bit far
and we're on the front line
the hope of a peace settlement um is
something that was never
actually worked for uh we saw zelm
signing a peace deal with the taliban
and there was a complete absence of a
roadmap for where the intra afan talks
were supposed to go
on the afghan side as well the political
elites have failed to see eye to eye and
come up with a
unified proposal for peace and the
international community is stuck
between two stances it is reluctant to
see them as the bad player
with ramifications to whatever war
crimes are being committed
in hopes of them coming to the
negotiating table at some point so the
current escalation
violence has draining the avant people
of whatever hope they had for
tomorrow there are people here who grew
up after
the collapse of the taliban regime they
don't remember what being refugees looks
like
it's going to be a very difficult
transition for them